okay colleagues we continue our meeting
how I switch into polish
please put your headphones on
otherwise yeah you can take mine
otherwise you will be forced to listen
it in my beautiful Polish language
okay
ladies and gentlemen dear colleagues
will start now the hearing that's 0.6
women's reproductive health and
specificities
including uh sexual and reproductive
health and rights and access to abortion
today I would like to welcome four
experts
we will hear their presentations
we've decided to organize this hearing
as it comes close to the international
safe Abortion Day which will happen in
nine days on the 28th of September
so I guess it's the right time to remind
of this important topic this is
something that affects millions of women
who live in Europe today
it's a topic that we've discussed on
numerous occasions has been subject to a
debate many times
and this is a topic that as
a very interesting the the European
parliament's stance is clear this is the
position that we have adopted on
numerous occasions let me just remind
you that reproductive health
has been a target of many so-called
anti-gender movements
and women's rights in many countries
have been Limited in terms of their
Reproductive Rights and I come from
Poland myself so after the last ruling
of the Constitutional tribunal we have
the situation in Poland in which women
in Poland cannot use their right to
abortion in 2019 for example in Poland
1100 abortions happened officially and
there are 40 million people living in
Poland and this is official data and
many women do that illegally in a
dangerous way
and today
last year
2022 it was only
161 women who had their pregnancies
terminated and 40 million people living
in Poland and his girls and women who
pay the highest price for this these
changes in law so this is what we'll be
discussing today with our experts Fred
matich is also here with us who deals
with this topic he's the author of a
famous report on Reproductive Rights so
Fred a very warm welcome to you as well
but it's our experts that are real stars
of today and with me introduce them
starting from my rate from my left Bill
gatefan how to direct a representation
office in Brussels U.N population fund
unfpa
it's a very well-known font we know it
because we've had representatives of
this Fund in this committee it is the
United Nations sexual reproductive
health agency which works in 150
countries worldwide then Dr yasenka grew
teacher phds specialist in Gynecology
and obstetrics from Croatia she is
famous for her defense of women's rights
including the right to abortion thank
you for being with us
next
year
and now I'm sorry next one is Leia
Sanchez she's an integrative
gynecologist and founder of
Alma by women an Integrative Health
Clinic in Spain a very warm welcome
thank you for being with us
and the last expert she'll take the
floor as the first one coming legal
advisor for Europe Center for
Reproductive Rights
it's a global human rights organization
that we know very well
it is an association of lawyers and
Advocates fighting for Reproductive
Rights
ladies and gentlemen so let us begin
each of you will have seven minutes
and then we'll open the debates and all
the colleagues will participate in the
discussion we'll have an exchange of
opinions
let me start with birgit Van Hood
and you have seven minutes
and then next experts over to you
thank you very much honorable chair
honorable members of the Femme committee
ladies and gentlemen I want to express
my gratitude first of all to this
committee for its unwavering support for
women and girls and I would like to
thank the Femme Committee in particular
for inviting me to be with you today my
focus will be on the global dimension of
sexual and reproductive health and
rights which I will refer to as srhr
the United Nations population fund as
our dear chair explained operates in
over 150 countries to bring about a
world where every pregnancy is wanted
every childbirth is safe women are free
from violence and the potential of every
young person is realized
in humanitarian settings where srhr has
traditionally been an afterthought let's
be honest we set up emergency delivery
rooms when maternity Wards are bombed
and we dispatch hospitals for rape
survivors like in Ukraine
in Afghanistan we run one of the largest
humanitarian operations providing safe
childbirth and psychosocial support for
women and girls which is literally a
Lifeline for thousands of pregnant women
and a massive number of young girls
thinking of committing suicide in
Afghanistan
in both humanitarian and development
contexts we partner with civil society
especially women and youth organizations
however
it is crucial to recognize that the
primary responsibility for upholding
human rights lies with States
in 1994 in Cairo 179 countries reached
to consensus at the International
Conference on population and development
the icpd to place women's reproductive
Health including Family Planning and
sexuality education at the heart of
development
in 2015 these commitments were largely
integrated into the sustainable
development agenda
complete with targets and indicators to
track progress towards the 2030 goals
so where do we stand Midway through the
sustainable development agenda
target tree one aim to reduce maternal
mortality to less than 70 per 100
000 live births
sadly zero progress since 2015 and even
regression by double digits in some
regions like the Americas
disproportionately affecting racial and
ethnic minorities like women and girls
of African descent
shockingly one woman dies every two
minutes from entirely preventable
pregnancy and childbirth related causes
and many more suffer life-altering
injuries like obstetric fistula women
and girls with disabilitating condition
tend to be stigmatized abandoned by
their husbands and ostracized by their
communities
yet obstetric fistula can be repaired
through surgery and there are some small
glimmers of Hope in West Africa for
example we've been advocating with the
ministries of Health together with some
European ambassadors and the private
sector to do more and as a result
several countries are now pledging to
allocate domestic resources
Target 3.7 of the sustainable
development agenda calls for Universal
which means 100 percent access to family
planning and modern contraception
unfortunately Global progress has been
really slow with access increasing by
only one percent from 76 into 76 percent
in 2015 to 77 today and it is projected
to increase to 78 percent meaning just
one more percentage
Point by 2030. sub-Saharan Africa lacks
most behind but the increase
from 51 to 57 percent clearly shows that
the problem is solvable
and the unfpa supplies partnership in
which the EU is a key partner has
contributed to these games
sustainable development goal 5 dedicated
to gender equality is entirely off track
Target 5.3 commits to eliminating
harmful practices
yet child marriage persists with one in
five girls becoming child brides and
forced marriages of girls under 14 on
the rise conflicts the pandemic the cost
of living crisis and climate change
further put in danger an additional 10
million girls
eradicating harmful practices requires
an intricate long-term labor of social
norms change and while we've made
strides against female genital
mutilation
population growth in high prevalence
countries is offsetting the gains that
we've made
indicator
5.6.1 measures the agency of married
women or women living in Partnership to
make decisions about sexual relations
family planning and contraception
shockingly forty four percent of women
with Partners lack the ability to make
these choices
this lack of agency illustrates the
clear link between srhr and the struggle
for women's rights and gender equality
more generally
gender equality remains far off possibly
taking another 300 years to achieve at
the current rate
at tsdg Summit taking place in New York
government leaders will hopefully decide
to rescue the sustainable development
agenda
but we rely on parliaments to hold
executive branches to account for their
human rights obligations both
domestically and internationally only
parliaments can ensure this
accountability
and that is what makes your political
support for srhr across party lines
vital
therefore we urge the Femme committee to
play an active role in evaluating the
gender action planetary in EU external
action
to ensure that srhr are Incorporated in
country level action plans or clips the
gender focal points are appointed in all
EU delegations
that srhr are systematically raised in
political and human rights dialogues
with partner countries
and that funding targets are met
we look forward as unfpa to partner with
the European Union on the global gateway
team Europe Initiative for srhr in
sub-Saharan Africa where our experience
in the region and our relationship with
the African Regional commissions can add
significant value
but more generally we call for the
establishment of a multi-stakeholder
Advisory Group for global gateway
initiatives
which would include the United Nations
and Civil Society
to ensure that all available experience
and expertise is tapped into for the
conceptualization of these initiatives
upstream and not only for implementation
Downstream that is if we want a global
gateway initiatives to be truly
transformative and sustainable
a model already exists in the global
gateway business Advisory Group
the Femme committee can also influence
EU funding for srhr where intentions
translate into action results and impact
in recent years EU financial support for
srhr has increased slightly in absolute
terms but decreased as a proportion of
official development Assistance or Oda
in fact the EU ranks 22nd out of 30 OAC
DAC donors for srhr lagging far behind
countries like the Netherlands Sweden
and Luxembourg which allocate an almost
four times higher proportion of their
official development assistance to srhr
we also faced challenges with the eu's
strictly project-based funding model
multi-year core funding for
organizations like ours would enable us
to respond swiftly to crisis and
catastrophes remain engaged in
protracted conflicts and support
advocacy efforts while reducing
transactional costs around 70 States
pledge core support
for agencies of the United Nations and
in our case for unfpa so we wonder why
can't the European Union do the same
the review of the EU multi-annual
Financial framework the mff including
the neighborhood development and
international cooperation instrument and
diki Global Europe presents a
significant opportunity for this
committee
more funding for the global challenges
thematic program could position the EU
as a global leader on srhr and allow for
continued investment in initiatives like
the supplies partnership and the
maternal Health Fund for which it has
proven so difficult to mobilize support
today as the chair mentioned we are
facing a global backlash against srhr
which is also tangible in multilateral
forum this makes the eu's principle
stance on srhr all the more essential
soon the 30th anniversary of the
International Conference on population
and development is coming up and the
need for a renewed Global political
consensus has never been greater
we invite the European Parliament and
the Femme Committee in particular to the
International parliamentarians
Conference on the implementation of the
icpd program of action which will take
place in Oslo from 10 to 12 April 2024
to take stock on where we are and chart
the way forward in these highly complex
times now is a pivotal moment to forge
effective alliances to tilt the balance
in the right direction time is of the
essence as the consequences of inaction
are high for women and girls and indeed
for all of us without srhr women cannot
fully enjoy any other human right
we need your leadership as
democratically elected representatives
to Champion srhr in Europe and globally
thank you so much
thank you very much
what an intervention thank you very much
thank you for that director so we
continue with Dr yasenka gruchit from
Croatia the florencia's doctor
put your mic on because you need to put
your mic on uh oh thank you very much
okay thank you
I would like to thank you for inviting
me and I'm always touched when hearing
this data from the world and
I'm aware of the tasks that is ahead let
me illustrate the situation in Croatia
please
next slide
the title of my presentation is could
you go back one slide so the title is
50 kilometers away
100 Years of Solitude
is a small town next to the creation
border
50 kilometers away from Zagreb and
I will explain this expression 100 Years
of Solitude during my presentation
next slide please
I dedicate this presentation to all
women
who had to or for various reasons wanted
to seek help with termination of
pregnancy abroad next slide please
the creation Gynecology and obstetrics
have a long and illustrious history
in 1870 in 1983 excuse the the first
child conceived by the social
fertilization was born it was the second
seventh child born in this way in the
world
next slide please
the right to decide freely on the birth
of children was incorporated into the
legislation of Yugoslavia briefly after
the second world war and it was
guaranteed by the 1974 Constitution and
in 1978
this was incorporated in the law on
health measures for exercising the
rights to a free decision on having
children this law is still enforced in
Croatia as it is in Slovenia as well
the law of medicine was promulgated in
2003 and this legalized the
conscientious objection in medicine
so conscientious objection a religious
Institute was incorporated into the
legislation of a secular country
this objection the refusal to do Duty
and denying care after abortion is
opposed to women's Reproductive Rights
first and foremost abortion and recently
now even contraception so
those women who want her to have an
abortion are being stigmatized as are
those who perform abortions
next slide please
on this occasion
I wanted to illustrate the situation in
Croatia
by analyzing the
situation in certain institutions but
owing to the goodness of my colleagues I
have been able to obtain the data on the
women who perform abortions in Slovenia
I focused in my research on 2022 in
Croatia we had
3041 elective abortions to 107 women
from Croatia terminated their pregnancy
in 2022 in the General Hospital brejita
in Slovenia
this data may not seem important to you
but when we compare this to the
population in Croatia this as a
significant piece of information
especially because we know that this
data
has possibly
some information that we will never
learn
next slide please
based on the law on the rights of access
to information I sent inquiries to
relevant institutions on the
availability of abortion Care on the
procedures and also on the denial of
abortion so I had to resort to the law
to obtain some information that my
colleagues are very unwilling to provide
thank you next slide yes
yes out of 30 authorized institutions
six of them turned a deaf ear to my
request
after resorting to a lawyer one of them
sent this information but to lays to
insert them in my presentation I will
continue to do research and I will
submit to this committee to the result
of my research
in three out of 24 authorized
institutions abortion care was not
provided
in 2022
in 2022 in eight
out of 24 institutions no medical
abortions were performed
in six hours of the 24 institutions no
surgical abortions were not performed in
2022 we could discuss at length why this
is happening but
unfortunately my time is limited
in 11 out of 24 institutions the women
could not choose the method and
I making you the example here of
universities clinics so in five out of
seven University clinics
60 to 83 percent of gynecologists
expressed a denial of abortion care in
one of these institutions none of them
refused abortion care and in one of them
29 of doctors did so next slide please
division is not something to be wished
for
uh criticized the medical community for
Bowing their heads to
attitudes that
deny
your rights or to women right to
reproductive and health care
the medical community has not
been able to improve the availability of
standard medical processes procedures
and Care the creation
health insurance does not cover abortion
costs unlike the Slovenian one and until
we've resolved this we cannot discuss
availability of abortion those of us who
Advocate reproductive Health in Croatia
I hope with your health will be able to
end this trend of unavailability and and
transparency of reproductive Health Care
I personally hope that
the independent performance of medical
abortion will be adopted as an
acceptable model of abortion care
so
Every Woman
who is forced to leave her country to
get abortion care to interrupt her
pregnancy
feels as if she were in 100 Years of
Solitude so this is there is a
long
path from the existence reproductive
Health Care in Croatia and
Slovenia which is only 50 kilometers
away from Sagar there is really a long
distance between those two thank you
thank you very much Dr Luigi thank you
for your presentation and I just want to
inform you that at the end of October we
will have a fact-finding mission to
create Shadows yeah the situation in the
ground so probably we'll meet again to
hog out deeper into what your
presentation I encourage my colleagues
if anyone wants to participate in this
Mission there is still a chance to join
us so we move now to uh Lila Santos
another doctor in our
expertise room who is a founder of Alma
by women the floor is yours doctor thank
you
and when buenos dias good morning
everybody and thank you very much for
inviting me to today's meeting I am a
gynecologist who specialize in hormones
and also in adolescent Gynecology and
I'd like to talk today about the need
for comprehensive sex and emotional
education including period education
which is an essential Factor we can move
on to the next slide please
in a survey carried out in 2019
more than 2 000 Spanish teenagers were
asked what they thought of the sex
education they had received 68 so almost
70 percent of those surveys said that
they thought it was insufficient next
slide please
sexual health is a human right so that
means having access to sex education not
just biology lessons is important they
need to know what kind of risks and
consequences there are in sexual
behavior
and they need to look at what to include
in this training next slide
I always say that sex education starts
at home starts in the Cradle babies need
mothers so we so mothers need to protect
babies right through from childbirth and
and this
then
uh sees teenagers will have a sex life
and they'll be able to be free from
depression if it starts early enough
and we also need to have a healthy
sexual life in when in adulthood
we see many changes in growth and
development in our adolescent
adolescence
the social cultural and family life
influences this and this will lead to a
biopsychosocial transformation next
slide please because human beings are
bio psychosocial beings
and sexuality develops in us from when
we're born
reproduction is part of sexual sexuality
but it's not just
um about intercourse it's also um
pregnancy it's also a child by this also
um breastfeeding so sex education needs
to include all of these things next
slide please we know that
um adolescence because of their
characteristics are a risk a population
at risk often they suffer the risks of
sexual relationships whether they could
be called risk risky relationships or
irresponsible relationships
50 percent of the new cases of STIs are
among teenagers or people from 15 to 25
and in the uh the chance of reinfection
is up to 40 percent in the first year
and these data here are similar to other
country High income countries this is
Spain and Catalonia
but this is about abortion
and this is
teen pregnancy
here we can see the data on the screen
and this reflects the reality of
adolescent adolescence
the lack of knowledge they have of their
menstrual cycle
and
there's a lack of information
about access
to uh
early assistance
and reproductive health care and the
negative consequences
of being pregnant
and breaking taboos of course there's
also
lack of perception about fertility next
slide please and other data is
um
is contraception this depends on each
autonomous community in Spain each
autonomous Community has different
methods of funding
and in 2017
the figure in Spain wasn't even 60
percent contraception rate
the this rate has improved since then
and so now up to 69 percent but perhaps
coincidentally
the rate of uh abortions has actually
decreased with this increase next slide
please another potential res next slide
please
it's the following slide please
and the previous one please
another another aspect of irresponsible
sex life is sexual violence and we don't
speak much about this we often think of
sex it's synonymous with pleasure
without any pressure but this is very
far removed from reality we're seeing
sexual violence especially among Miners
and teenagers is very problematic here
there is a uh a graph
like a pie chart this is data from
Catalonia and this is data up to 2022 up
to 40 percent of uh victims of sexual
violence are minors underage
so you can see that there is a re
repressive hypersexualized vision of
women and women are subject to this
often
there is
myths of romance and porn culture which
leads to the objectification of women
and also one of the main sources of sex
education more than 65 percent have
already consumed pornography so
pornography is the main source of sex
education for many people
this we need to allow our teenagers to
be free of sex sexual repression but we
also we can prevent sexual violence and
previous slide please
and pressure
we need to have a comprehensive sex and
emotional education we need to empower
own our own health including Sexual
Health we need to have
to take decisions based on information
and we also need to be consistent in
these decisions decisions we need to
include menstruation periods in this
education as well this is a key part of
human dignity we know that topics such
as sexual Freedom
male violence and abuse are issues which
are knelt not dealt with in that kind of
information
skip two slides please
the next one and then the next one
the next one
so menstruation is a physiological
process which affects
um the half of the worst population for
around 40 Years of their lives
and
it is a very important aspect and it
needs to be free of taboo but what is
the reality in your next goes to the
next slide please the next slide is that
94 of women between 10 and 20 have
period pains and 91 percent of those
women play down those symptoms and they
don't believe that they will need to
have medical assistance
and often women go through five years of
medical visits without actually
receiving a diagnosis
and girls will often miss one to four
days a month because of period pains and
this has an impact on their school
performance and this increases the
gender gap
the reality is chronic period pains is
the main risk factor in anxiety and
depression among teenagers
and this means
that teenagers can then be subject to
various types of violence
we've seen data support this in
humanitarian crises
child marriage
forced marriage and
disability gender identity
many factors
and this leads to stigma among around
periods
and it makes it difficult for teenage
girls to exercise their rights next
slide please
so period education is a sexual right
because the menstrual cycle is a Vital
sign and it
prevent uh
pathologies and um
disorders among women not just think
analogical health
period education allows us to break with
taboos in society discrimination and
gender-based violence for many reasons
next slide please so if we don't talk
about periods all their Stars
is actually
sustain these uh negative stereotypes
and attitudes therefore we can't talk
about sexual health without talking
about period health and therefore
we cannot allow
the menstrual Health to deteriorate
there's the abortion launch has changed
in Spain and this is a commitment to
protecting sexual reproductive rights of
women and to fight for this
comprehensive sex and emotional
education which is very important
so our teenagers will see improvements
to Safe abortions they'll see a
reduction in Regional differences and
inequalities and access to abortion and
will see better access to contraception
as well
and hope this comprehensive sex and
emotional education will be a key
measure to prevent gender-based violence
and gender inequality next slide please
the many things that need to be done in
Catalonia where I work this year we
started
a program
where we
urge women to use environmentally
friendly hygiene materials
so
we also provide contraception
which is free until the age of 29.
and there's also a framework for
abortions
we also want to
provide assistance with suction
reproductive Health consultations for
people under the age of 25 for sexual
health and biological problems special
consultations in different hospitals and
also continuous education training on
sexual health and Gynecology for
professionals to conclude and the next
slide please defending Reproductive
Rights and sexual rights for women and
periods as part of their biology
helps to combat violence
to end gender-based stereotypes the
normalization of symptoms and also
improve treatment and diagnosis for
women
the hormonal cycle can impact Women's
Health and what we need to do is
um lead stop the research the Gap in
gender gap in research as well thank you
Sanchez really interest
and now we go further with the next
speaker I will say welcome to miss
Camilla Jervis
the word is yours
honorable chair
um honorable members of the fam
Committee of the European Parliament
thank you for inviting the Center for
Reproductive Rights to present before
this committee on this important matter
as many of you know the center Works
across Europe and other regions to
advance laws and policies on sexual
reproductive health and rights and
prevent backsliding
we can go to the next slide please
thank you in the short time we have I
want to briefly capture some of the key
trends and concerns in relation to
sexual reproductive health and rights in
Europe
and first I think it's important to
underscore that the trend in the region
is broadly Progressive so since 2018 as
you can see on the slide over 15
countries have liberalized their
abortion laws by removing bans and
access barriers
next time next slide please since 2020
states are also increasingly adopting
laws and policies mandating free or
subsidized access to contraception
and to ensure that
all women have equal access including
The Pedestrian couples to assisted
reproductive Technologies
but despite all of this there is still
significant needs in every EU member
state for further Progressive reform so
that sexual reproductive health and
rights are fully realized for women in
Europe
and as other speakers have mentioned we
are witnessing blacklash and regressions
in some parts of the EU which have a
significant effect on women's Access to
Health Care
continued progress is the most effective
way of tackling these regressive threats
so international human rights law
clearly prohibits States from taking
deliberately retrogressive measures when
it comes to existing rights
unfortunately legislators and
governments in some new countries have
not adhered to these obligations and
have actively rolled back existing
entitlements I will focus on regression
on abortion access and then I will give
a few examples of regression in other
areas of reproductive Health Care
on abortion most of the time it read
eradicating entitlement is slow it can
be Insidious starting with seemingly
harmless rhetoric and the spread of
misinformation at first
but very quickly over time it shifts
into concrete attempts to roll back
entitlements
often attacks on sexual productive
health and rights go hand in hand with
attacks on Democratic principles and the
rule of law
and this is clear from what has happened
in relation to abortion in Poland in
Hungary and in Slovakia
next line please
so when it comes to Poland as the chair
recalled in the beginning of this
presentation
the law was already one of the most
restrictive in Europe and as you know
there were repeated attempts over many
years to ban abortion fully these were
combined with successful efforts to
dismantle the independence of the
Judiciary and that culminated in 2020
with Poland becoming the only EU member
states in recent history to remove a
ground for legal abortion from its laws
so now we have a de facto ban on
abortion in place
this is having very grave impacts on the
lives health and well-being of women in
Poland next slide please
in Hungary incremental regression has
occurred over time in 2000 the
government introduced regressive
restrictions on access to abortion
namely a mandatory waiting period and
mandatory bias counseling
then in 2011 the revised Constitution
explicitly protected life from
conception
and last year as many of you know a
ministerial decree introduced a
requirement obliging women to listen to
the fetal ultrasound prior to abortion
next slide please
in Slovakia again regressive threats
have come in waves so in 2009 laws
introduced new regressive requirements
prior to abortion such as mandatory
waiting period
and since 2018 over 20 regressive draft
bills seeking to place new limits on
access to abortion have been tabled
repeatedly by anti-abortion
parliamentarians the most recent was
just a few months ago
they have been rejected each time but
the votes have been very close
so as I mentioned not only abortion but
also other aspects of Women's Healthcare
have been targeted next slide please
for example in 2017 legislation in
Poland abolished the sale of emergency
contraception over the counter by
reintroducing the requirement for a
prescription
and recently in Italy the central
government has required local
governments to remove the recognition of
legal Parenthood for non-biological
mothers of children born from IVF
next slide please
backslash is also affecting civil
society and human rights Defenders
working on sexual reproductive health
and rights
for example in Poland were not only
regression has regression led to Health
Care being limited but it also LED on
Clem down on human rights Defenders
working on Reproductive Rights
in March 2023 yustina witherenska whom
you know she spoke before this committee
was officially convicted for the crime
of helping with an abortion
this was the first prosecution of its
kind in the EU and other human rights
defenders in Poland and elsewhere are
facing prosecution for the organization
of abortion rights protests and for
simply defending the right to abortion
so what can the EU institutions do to
ensure that we continue to make progress
on women's reproductive health and
address the regression that has occurred
and the threats that remained thank you
first it is Paramount to strengthen
legal and policy protection of sexual
reproductive health and rights at EU
level based on public health standards
though you can do much more under its
existing competencies on a number of
issues pertaining to sexual reproductive
health and rights
then there must be stronger and more
consistent action by EU institutions
when threats of backsliding and
regression occurs this should involve
closing monitoring of the threats early
warning mechanisms and the full use of
the rule of law toolbox to address them
finally human rights Defenders and Civil
Society organizations working on sexual
reproductive health and rights need
increased political backing and
financial support as they continue to
confront many challenges and are the
Forefront of efforts to advance sexual
productive health and rights
I want to close by saying the most
effective way to counter regression is
ensuring that progress continues we know
there is currently potential for
Progressive reform in Denmark in Germany
in Ireland among others we know that the
EU is negotiating a very important
legislation
on women's rights
it is critical to use these processes to
continue advancing sexual reproductive
health and rights as we have seen that
standing still is not an option
and in the meantime we have to stand in
solidarity with human rights Defenders
and Civil Society in those countries
that are bearing the brunt of regression
thank you very much for your time and
attention
[Applause]
thank you very much
for your intervention and to all of you
for your Excel and all of you had
excellent interventions I myself I
really appreciated that and I'm sure my
colleagues as well
I mentioned my colleagues because now is
the time for them to
intervene ask questions make comments
and I have whole list of my colleagues
wishing to take the floor and we go
Group by group first and then I open the
floor for the rest of my colleagues and
the first one is my colleague from Epp
Isabella adinolfi for two and a half
minutes each yeah thank you sir
today would we focus mainly on the right
to abortion and as you know we've been
fighting together for years because this
is a right and as such it must be
guaranteed to every EU woman
citizens but if we want to talk about
the overall dimension of Reproductive
Rights of women we have to cite from two
different points first is that not every
woman are the same in Europe they don't
all have the same rights in Europe
secondly some problems are hardly ever
faced up to and as legislators we must
make efforts to be clearer in our texts
why am I saying this first of all
as the second category the issues that
are very often
not talked about in types of law is the
issue of contraception access to
contraception is not the same throughout
the EU for economic issue because costs
vary widely for a cultural issue because
not all gynecologists are the same from
country to Country and even within the
same countries
sometimes a really wide diff widely
differently position
and then there's an educational issue
teenagers are not informed I talk I was
talking in Naples with one of the
largest hospitals the south of Italy for
STDs and
I had the same results as you just
expounded on Dr Sanchez and then not all
women are the same because there are
illnesses that are not talked about such
as endometriosis which is relatively
newly talked about and then there's an
issue not just of the taboos of
intercourse but also becoming mothers
European women are becoming mothers
later and later in life but there is no
homogeneous
policy on uh cryo-conservation of uh the
over
we need to
insert and write
the educational part in our tax law
because gynecologists must be obliged to
tell women and advise them to save their
over given our birth
Decline and there are no rights for
single women in a lot of countries a lot
of Italian women for example go to Spain
to get uh ivf's
this is a very interesting debate
because it's given us a lot of food for
thought but let me ask everyone to make
efforts to be as explicit as possible
and try and
insert in our text as many issues as
possible thank you who's that in office
The Next Step
is
snd
[Music]
Fred Matic
uh
thank you very much Robert I would like
to thank all the experts Who provided us
with very useful information today as
you know this committee pays a lot of
attention to sexual and Reproductive
Rights especially the right to abortion
and I'm very pleased that today we have
yet another opportunity to discuss this
issue and an opportunity to emphasize
that women still do not have the rights
to this which is one of the human rights
I was special especially alarmed by the
presentation of Dr gruich we are often
here discussing the situation in Hungary
Poland or Malta and some small countries
such as Croatia fall under the Raider
and there although the legislation is in
place in reality it is very difficult to
access size this right sexual and
Reproductive Rights are among
fundamental human rights this is not an
ideological issue this is the public
health issue and this is how we will
continue to approach it
so here in the parliament we voted on
the resolution where two years ago where
we voiced very clearly our demands and
we addressed the commission and the
national governments unfortunately two
years later not much has changed we
still do not have European standards in
this field so this is not just a
political message to the parliament
which shows that what we vote on here is
not a priority for the other two
branches of the EU
EU political
landfill but it's also a message to the
women across Europe
unfortunately it is just Brave
gynecologists ngos foundations Civil
Society organization patients that fill
in this void and that actually
provide the services to these women that
this regular
regular government institutions are not
providing so once again I would like to
voice my demand we need to provide the
same standards across Europe and not
hide ourselves behind the same line that
we always use and this is the this is
National competence we cannot leave
women on their own thank you
and we go to Greens now Gwendoline
now it will be at least thank you
Maurice yes thank you Cher and thank you
so much for uh our speakers being here
with us and sharing your knowledge
with respect of the time I will just ask
one a quick question I'm from Sweden and
uh even for us of course I mean we
we have a very strong right to decide
over our own body but
there are movements
influenced by the U.S and by Finance by
the U.S that are pointing in another
Direction and I am especially worried
about this conscious
tool that the use and try to use so I
wonder to Dr Gross what have you done in
a study or interviews with all these
professionals within Healthcare that are
using the argument or
leaning towards their rights that they
have to use their their conscious and
not helping women with their rights
thank you
and from ECR I have Margarita de la Pisa
carrion
okay now try now
no no no yes
thank you to defend the rights of women
you have to know women I'm happy for
doctors Sanchez for having talked about
the physical
physiology of women because this has to
do with emotional
psychological and other dimensions of
women
which make us women
and a natural
will wish to become mothers
and for most of us
promoting the access to abortion as the
right is really a nightmare
abortion is something that goes against
women is the utmost non-right
it's a manipulation and I'm sensitive
moment such as pregnancies because women
are faced with insecurity fear senses
such as you'll be alone your life is
over what are you gonna do you'll never
make it so what we're gonna do if we
analyze these messages
are they're extortionists
they don't want their babies or they
can't have their babies there's all
these pressures defending women's rights
is guaranteeing that they get all the
support and not social pressure that
points them to a decision that can't be
changed and many times they would they
regret so let me ask you are you aware
of what you're promoting because
there is a reality that's hiding behind
data
um resilient demographic growth uh
um voluntary
abortion choice
progress is incompatible with not
respecting women and the life
We cannot put this in question who
deserves to live and who doesn't
would a fast child have more rights to
live than a fifth
when my mother was 45
I came into this world today is my
birthday life is a gift
and
being born is the greatest gift
so if as human beings we don't protect
women in wanting to have their babies
where Society going mothers don't want
to abort we must avoid to be
self-destructive in the interests of
anti-natality
big business I hope this will animate
the discussion thing
thank you dear colleague happy birthday
today happy birthday to you Margarita
and I want to ask whether yes Karin has
Karin Olson
yeah we continue
thank you for giving
the game that I will continue in Swedish
uh oh
what I'd like to start by doing is
thanking all the speakers for their very
interesting
points of view
we're witness to a situation at the
moment where women's rights are in
Jeopardy in the world and in some
countries
um
uh Aid is being paid to other countries
to
um
promotes certain attacks against uh
women's rights the rights to sexual
reproductive Health around the world and
it's important to ensure that
we don't threaten the life in this way
and I think it's making in some cases
abortion into a business make it more
dangerous we'd need a a way of tackling
this which faces women's rights higher
up the agenda and we need a more
feminized foreign policy I would
therefore ask you what is your view of
the situation and
I'd like to hear from very different on
this first of all particularly what is
required to reduce
um
access to Safe abortions what is the
relationship
to women's access to
Safe Care and
full access to sexual sexual
Reproductive Rights I'd like to have a
little bit more a detail on that now
Gwendoline the black coffee
[Music]
chemistry showed it it's it's a mixed
landscape and we have some progress in
some places and some difficulties coming
back in others and indeed it's very
linked to also a backlash in rule of law
in general as we can see in Hungary but
I have an another concern more and more
and we discussed it not long ago with
Mrs Natalie Camen I have the the concern
of the demography issue and we are going
to start to hear a narrative about the
fact that we are not having enough young
people in in EU certain countries where
there is a backlash on rule of law
instead of thinking of the uh
sad environment they give to their young
people they prefer to see the pro only
the problem of not having enough birth
at the same
um at the same moment we are not wanting
migrants on our Shores that could be
sometimes these people that we knew our
countries and I feel that the demography
issue is going to come back very high as
a burden on on women's body and once
again this will be the solution so we're
going to ask the EU woman to have more
children and we are going to ask the
others to have less children because of
course they are having too many children
outside of EU and we're having two Less
in EU and once again the solution to
these very uh International Deep
structural problems that could be
challenged in a number of ways are going
to be
um about the body of women so I think
that for all our panelists if they if
could they could elaborate on this and
then just a point of information but
maybe Lena will make it too is that we
are working in this Parliament on a big
text on treaty changes not you know
exhaustive treaty changes the essential
ones
um and very clearly this commission said
that one of the Tweety changes that we
wanted as essential if we had to only
choose a few in in all of the domains
the one for firm would be indeed the
sexual and Reproductive Rights to be a
European competence as as
when Matic said that it's we don't hide
behind the argument of it being only a
national competence and we are seeing in
AFCO that there's not a lot of interest
in all groups about this and the once
again this is seen as a an accessory
question uh we could come out uh in in a
few weeks with a text coming from this
Parliament not having this issue in it
and we have to fight in all of our
groups about this because I think that
there's really a problem of
mentality and also because of course one
of the most men
um uh Committee of this of this uh
Parliament that you know this is yes it
is important but come on not that
important
well done thank you very much and the
last voice will be to Lina Galvez Munoz
and with this I need to come back to our
distinguished guests because we are
running out of time Lina
it is just to to confirm sorry I was
Voting in interest so I couldn't listen
to you so I will not make any uh direct
comment but just what Wonderland was was
was saying it was a very clear
message from this committee they have
not even taken into consideration so
this is yeah of course is the most major
dominated uh
um committee here in this Parliament the
contrary of this one is like a positive
a negative of this one but I think we
should really make something because
they have taken just few of our uh
amendments and the other day they were
not even interested in listening in the
in the uh what I have to say as from
proporture and so I think we really need
to to to do something and especially to
to make pressure to include abortions
European
issue thank you very much thank you very
much Lina I just assure you that I as a
chair I took a lot of effort to persuade
the AFCO members now to to take on your
site it's really very very difficult and
but I will continue you can count on me
as well so thank you very much okay with
this we come back to our distinguished
guests and you have three minutes each I
don't know how you will make it but the
first is Bill Gideon and then we
continue with other guests the floor is
your director
thank you very much thank you for your
questions and for the very interesting
discussion maybe let me start with the
international dimension of the abortion
and just to start by indicating that
unfpa and the UN system does not comment
on domestic policies or promote changes
to the legal status however
in a 1994 in Cairo the International
Community agreed that where abortion is
legal it should be safe and accessible
and it also stipulated that every woman
is entitled to
post-abortion care
now what do we what we know from our
work is that banning abortion does not
end it and it only increases unsafe
abortions
we see unsafe abortions as one of the
leading causes of maternal death in the
global South it causes up to 13 percent
of all maternal deaths and hospitalizes
about 7 million women a year globally
according to our estimates 45 of
abortions that are carried out in the
countries where we work are unsafe and
that unsafe abortion alone accounts for
about 39
000. that's globally every year
regarding the question on uh the
pressure uh the question of demography
fertility pressure on women's fertility
and it's interesting because I had the
opportunity not so long ago to speak
also to the the sap now the oacp as the
African Pacific and Caribbean States
organization and the same anxiety that
women here experience about this
pressure on their fertility rate that
we're not producing sufficient uh
children they perceive it the exact
opposite manner they asked continuously
the question what is this obsession with
the fact that we are found to have too
many children try and that it is up to
states to empower people to achieve
their individual reproductive goals not
to try to control women or to reduce
their agency so we must radically
rethink the discourse and I think be
very distrustful of some of the
narratives that we're hearing about
demographic changes and make sure that
this does not undermine women's rights
thank you
thank you perfect timing thank you very
much director and now we go to Dr
yasenka gruich for her comments and
remarks you put the mic on please
thank you
foreign
thank you very much first of all I would
like to answer the MEP from Sweden you
asked me what we have done in order
to counter those who do not perform
their duties
I was working in the private sector when
this happened for the first time in 2014
and I have to say that I was shocked
um that was the time when the older
doctors uh professionals were still
performing abortion and when this
conscientious objection was
introduced I need to say that this is a
religious instrument and this is my firm
belief this has nothing to do with human
rights
so
in 2014 we organized a very large round
table discussion together with some ngos
we discussed this issue and we realized
that this was an enormous problem but
that it was not recognized by the
official
institutions and by the majority of
Health Care Service or they actually
supported it so even many medical
doctors accepted
this position
whereby it is the right of the fetus
that is in the focus
so they did not understand that we
primarily championed the interests and
the health of women and they put
Priority on the interests of fetus so
this is the main problem so our
initiative gained a lot of support
our proposals are still online
proposals regarding possible regulation
of this issue
many of my colleagues stated that they
would not perform abortion for religious
reasons
and this is something that is very hard
to resolve game of the statistical
data so in many University clinics
including
the med schools
Clinic has these statistics whereby
nearly 80 percent of gynecologists are
refusing to perform abortion then in
another town all gynecologists are
performing abortion so it also depends
on how you select
people you employ in a certain
institution this is the only way I can
explain this
I'm afraid that this can only be
resolved through some labor issues so if
you are a gynecologist this is one of
your duties it is a woman who is your
patient and you know people to provide
care to that woman I don't know whether
this response is satisfactory for you
I'm afraid that at the moment the
medical community is completely
different provided in Croatia
then the lady said that every life is a
gift I do agree among those living every
life is a gift but also please
understand my point of view I'm 72. I've
been a gynecologist for a long time and
I will never forget the women
um
who came to
the hospital
um having sustained major
major damage because of criminally
performed
abortion although the legislation was
already in force so when we talk about
the gift of life this is what I remember
so I do not Champion abortion my first
role as a gynecologist was to do my best
to reduce the number of abortions
our initiative also
um came up with a proposal for a new
legislation which is not called the
abortion law it is called an act on
overall sexual uh education
contraception and abortion uh
unfortunately any woman who has to go
for an abortion for any of the reasons
will certainly do it believe me
and in this segment there can be
no enforcing of anybody so you cannot
force anybody to be pregnant
nor can you force anybody to go for an
abortion
so this is my response to your questions
how can we ensure and access
on this sentence ever say hello
in conclusion then I will just address
the issue of the population I would like
to say that as I wrote a book I
considered this issue the problems with
depopulation and contraception in
Croatia and I concluded that
contraception is important in order to
preserve reproductive Health in Croatia
three minutes I remind you thank you
who as women and gynecologist I want to
answer
adinolfe
the problem is that women has been
ignored by their health system because
everything that has to do merely with
women has never been interesting to the
Health Systems that's why we never
talked about endometriosis and women
sometimes had to wait for eight or ten
years to get a diagnosis
uh so this is yet another example of a
medical system that ignores women as
such now
everything that has to do with maternity
obviously a gynecologist
uh role is promoting a woman's fertility
that declines with age
but it's a very important to have a
holistic
sexual and emotional education so that
you learn about fertility both in
females and males and how the is
lifestyle and external factors can
infrases
and then the law
we need a homogeneous law on the
preservation of Frozen embryos and over
and also the training of not just
gynecologists but also midwives
and these people should keep up the set
the health education so that women know
that if they become pregnant
uh if they don't become pregnant by a
certain age it's not that their Pastor
sell by date but they might have
problems in later
pregnancies now to answer Mr lapisa
having access to a secure safe abortion
there's no incompatible with the this
natural desire of women to become
mothers
this is also a question of the context
in how we raise
little girls because there is this uh
societal pressure that you can't be
properly a woman if you don't become a
mother but will we why we want a safe
abortion is that women who don't want to
become women the mothers they will
anyway resort to abortion so when
abortions are not legal they become
dangerous and very often the woman dies
so the gift of life is also making sure
that women stay healthy
when a teenager comes to my office uh
pregnant I always find that it's a
failure of our health and educational
system because
I've been insisting on the importance of
a sex and a well-being education since
very early childhood so that
teenagers can then
decide on their sexual activity and
reproductive health
on their own without being subject to
peer pressure and abuses
so that they can be protected even if
they do decide to be sexually active so
that we have to prevent teenage
pregnancies through
education and
contraception
not so much that a doctor should
actively promote it if it doesn't wish
to but at least to put the information
out there
because a lot of times women
are bought because not so much because
they don't want the baby but because
they feel that there are no structures
to let them be mothered so is this
incompatible with a safe abortion law no
we need to ask a different question we
need to ask what is in place to support
women and in what conditions
sorry for running over
we could talk for hours on this
and the last of the speaker is Camille
jerve for three minutes thank you very
much thank you I will be very brief
um I want to thank the members of this
committee first of all for your
unwavering support when it comes to
sexual reflective health and rights and
especially with regards to the process
currently underway in AFCO
um I would like to recall that the
reason why we absolutely need to remain
hopeful is that regression and backlash
that we're seeing is a clear result of
the overwhelming progress which has
taken place these past years and I think
regression is intensifying in some
places precisely because we are seeing
strides of great progress and these are
losses for the anti-rights movement and
again I think the most effective way to
counter regression is ensuring that
progress continues
um and so in the meantime I think we
need to use the tools that we do have
and the processes that we do have to
ensure progress on sexual reproductive
health and rights and it starts with
very concrete things like ensuring that
an EU directive clearly mandates sexual
reproductive Health Care access
including abortion but not only for
victims of sexual violence and I think
you have an opportunity to achieve just
that with the violence against women
directive
um and and to ensure that this directive
also has very strong provisions on
comprehensive sexuality education as
prevention measures because indeed it is
important as Mrs edinolti said to
address the full spectrum of sexual
reproductive health and rights sexual
reproductive health and weights meds
absolutely become a priority for the
next European Parliament and the next
European commission and we have seen
that regression happens through
incremental steps over time the
challenge is in effectively preventing
this regression lies not only in
monitoring the regression and I think
you have all very good access to
information about the types of
regression that happens and when these
changes are looming but I think the
challenge mostly lies in unequivocal and
prompt reaction and condemnation of
those threats and the rollbacks on
existing entitlements and on Defenders
of these existing entitlements and I
think this is where we need to improve
is the reaction part when we have these
threats
um and and so the current the current
process in AFCO would be a very very
positive step to not hide behind
National competence and ensure that we
have full EU capability to address the
full spectrum of sexual reproductive
health and rights
and we look forward to continuing
working with you on these important
matters hopefully also during the next
term thank you very much I will stop
here because I know we're running out of
time
thank you very much
thank you very much to all of you thank
you to The Experts for your excellent
interventions and thank you for being
with us I'm sure this is not the last
time we are meeting each other so yes
thank you have a good day thank you very
much
okay
okay colleagues we continue the
committee meeting